as weird I gave you a bit mikuni key
right as in this shape right you have a
choice when you have a shape you like I
don't know how to deal with it by the
way the reason why it's tricky is
because the area and I had this
conversation about the area of a
parallelogram at least the way you
learnt it is base times perpendicular
height right now base number one like
bases any of these sides but you don't
have it in a nice form right you don't
know what this length is except by
appealing to the distance formula which
gives you some kind of algebraic mess
even if you work out what that is then
how do you work out the perpendicular
height you can learn the perpendicular
distance formula and you can take one of
these points and then work out the
equation of this line and then work out
that distance with the absolute value
but really really okay so so you don't
want to go there okay there's a simple
way like I said here's an example right
when a shape is weird
you either divide it up into less weird
things or you find it we're then
something that's less were you okay
so this is this is a coordinate system
right so for example if I put a
rectangle here
okay now that looks a bit weird but
again I can divide this up pretty easily
can't I I know heaps of later example
have a look down here see this triangle
you know how big that triangle is right
what are the dimensions of this triangle
it's a by B isn't it that's a there and
that'll be be there yes okay how about
this shape over here what's that that's
a rectangle right how tall is it come on
guys happen that's all the rectangle
it's still big it's a rectangle okay how
wide is it it's C okay so you know this
is you know what this is
Oh huh what about this what shape is
this
it's a it's a triangle with what's its
base you'll see what's the height now
I'll keep going just because I can but
you don't need anymore do you
because the shape is symmetrical right
so you for example you have a look up
here right what's this guy this triangle
here do you recognize it from somewhere
looks like it's a baby right isn't it
and then you have a look over here
that's going to be yet be my city I see
baby okay and then this one look it's
it's vertical coordinate is D right
you're done okay so watch no distance
for it no Pythagoras no trick okay
what's the area of the big rectangle yep
okay so what do I have to take away to
leave me with the parallelogram start
with the easy things I got two
rectangles right what are you hearing
the rectangles what else do I have to
take away
I have to take away two triangles with
this dimension right which is half a B
right and then I've got and then I've
got two more triangles to get rid of
right what are the dimensions of that
half CD CD CD C D yep okay all right
explain for me yeah - okay this guy -
this guy - hold on a sec this is going
to be one of these left that's it that's
a see that should look ma no square
roots okay now are you ready you like
what was the point of that are we doing
matrices exactly right see this thing
here this thing here
right we started with this okay started
with this right this guy down here a
times D minus B times C right if you
call this let's call this matrix a this
guy down here is called the determinant
of a in this particular case in this
particular case the determinant of this
matrix gives you the area of this
parallelogram hmm okay now I'm going to
pause you for a sec let you digest that
now this is a matrix is 2x2
which is why I was able to draw in two
dimensions okay but as you said before
right the whole idea is to take
something simple and then see how far it
can take you now we've already dealt
with much bigger matrices of this much
much bigger right so for instance I've
got a bit of space over here
this is 2x2 right and when you express
it as when you take it to represent a
couple of vectors right you get a 2d
shape
what would you anticipate you would get
if I gave you instead a matrix like this
what would you think that that's
referring to this year right two vectors
two dimensions
yeah like left right then up down what
do you think this is talking about this
is talking about depth right this is a
um this is a three-dimensional figure
okay now this this starts to give it
half of it because I have a
two-dimensional board right but I can
tell you right now the shape we got here
was a parallelogram okay now this is in
three dimensions this is in three
dimensions if you have a 3d shape right
and you make it out of six squares right
you put if you if you fold unfolded six
squares right and then you put them
together
what would this name of that shape in
it's a cube right if they're squares now
if we take six rectangles right you
won't get a cube anymore will you
assuming the rectangles are not also
squares okay what would you get we get a
rectangular prism ah but but see see
these things right if you get a pay you
will get a parallelogram so therefore
what would you expect it to be cold
if you got six pallets parallelograms
and made a figure from that yes well I
had to UM I had to look up the name just
to make sure I spelled it right I'm not
joking
this is called a you get a Jarryd Hayne
no I'm you get it you get a
parallelepiped
okay I don't know who made up that name
but it's very cute okay now let me
quickly draw one for you okay you know
you know what she looks like right so
there's my there's my cute looking thing
okay you know what a rectangular prism
looks like they're not too hard
something like that so what would a
parallel of look like I need some more
space I'll do it down here
all of them all of the faces are going
to be parallelogram okay so you'll get
something like this now this is not this
is not perspective this is it's an
actual parallelogram okay so this
there's one face okay and then if you
have a look at the top oh now this is
not it's not perspective okay here ah
that's actually a rectangle on top and
we're looking at it from an angle but
this is not it's actually a
parallelogram okay and then of course
this last sign here of course that will
also be a parallelogram that make sense
so I could
whoa hey girl
so there's my parallel Tipton okay you
can see as well you can see where the
vectors are I'll draw them in for you
look see there's the first vector
there's the second vector where's the
third one
where's the third one look at it it's
going it's going into the board isn't it
it's this guy now I'll teach you another
important work because this is pretty
cool right um they're all of these these
axes here I'd see these axes these axes
are perpendicular we're used to that we
always have access that a perpendicular
right it's like well look at this third
axis the one that's going into the board
right it's also perpendicular but in a
different way
right so when perpendicularity goes into
water but in directions like this we
call it orthogonal okay so it's like
it's like perpendicular but more
dimensions coming into play okay
I won't make you try to imagine what
would happen if we had a four by four
matrix my brain is already taxed them
out okay but I don't know I don't think
I can draw it okay I can barely draw it
three bytes